Is your tongue split?
Can you go like this?
Ah! [laughs]
[music playing]
[woman] At the Sacramento County Jail,
there are over 2,400
male and female inmates.
[man] Okay, yuck it up, ass jackal,
you're on camera.
[laughing]
Being here in jail, it'll break you.
[screams]
[woman 2] Ten percent of
the population here are women.
[woman 3] I got charged with
assault with a deadly weapon.
-[woman 4] Home invasion.
-[woman 5] Murder and robbery.
[woman 6]
Wanna tell me a little bit about that?
Nope.
[female guard] It's human nature
for inmates here to break rules.
We can't catch everything.
[male guard] People are passing contraband
through the toilets.
It's nasty.
Yeah, there's regulations, but there's
so many relationships, it's ridiculous.
[woman 7] Were two incarcerated people
who are about to get married.
Yo, yo. I talk to a guy.
I met him through the toilet.
You dialing me. What's up?
These people are different in here.
These is like wild baboons.
-Who do you think you're talking to?
-Back it up.
And this place is clearly crazy.
I don't care about none of that.
If you snitch, you're gonna meet my fist.
Something's gonna pop off.
Everybody, easy! Lock it down, now!
I don't wish jail on anybody,
'cuz it's not fun in here.
But if you can find a good friend in here,
it makes the time very easy.
I love you too, Monster.
We might be locked up physically,
but mentally and emotionally...
I'm rolling. I'm rolling. [laughs]